The the funny thing is, those people who
come in and give hate to Central C are
the same people who are God knows doing
what evil sins in their home. And you're
there chatting oh you're mocking the
religion. My friend, do you really take
your religion seriously? Is it why don't
you stop all those sins that you're
doing?
This is One Ummah Sadaqah Jariyah video.
If you care about the dunya more than
the akhirah, skip it. By one donation,
you're going to help 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people who've been fed
through the emergency food aid. You are
going to be sponsoring 4,200 orphans.
You will be helping 250,000 people in
Gaza. You'll be helping 123,000
people to be fed through our Qurbani
program. You will help feed 551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 masajid that are going to be built
around the world. And 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
One Ummah 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep it 100%, we need
you to help us by supporting this fund
so that all of the stuff that I
mentioned, you get the reward for every
single one of them. It's far more
important than the dunya. And you will
see every penny that you give on Yawm
al-Qiyamah. The decision is yours. The
link is there. Donate now. As-salamu
alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh,
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys are well, inshallah. So,
as you guys may know or not know,
Central C, who's a rapper, I don't know
nothing about don't know his popularity,
but has accepted Islam. So, this is
someone, if I'm not mistaken, is in the
rap world, etc. We know how the rap
world is.
From the lyrics to the lifestyle to God
knows what goes behind the scenes,
subhanallah, with all this madnesses,
subhanallah. They live in a very dark
world. You get it? Everything is
materialism, hedonism, selfishness about
oneself, pure desires,
and it's it's it's a scene where a lot
of people live depressed, drug abuse,
and whatever it is for that matter,
inshallah.
They are their soul is deprived. Their
soul is starving, and that's why they
sometimes turn into spirituality. So,
Central C, it seems like when you live
that lifestyle, and I can kind of relate
in the sense where I I wasn't a rapper,
but I I a similar lifestyle. And that
lifestyle, what it does, it leaves you
empty because you're you're trying to
get the next high. You're living for
other people. And this is so depressing
because the people that are around you,
be it your girlfriend or boyfriend or
money this that and friends around you,
you don't know if they're there for you
for for real, if they are genuine
friends. And it's such a depressing life
to know that you are with someone do not
know if that person is genuinely there
for you or for different reasons. And
because you live in a society where
everything is about selfishness and
oneself, it's a very depressing place to
be because in Islam it's not about
selfishness. It's about the community.
It's about your brother and sister.
That's why the prophet said, "Love for
your brother and sister what you love
for yourself." And when you have a
community like here in Salah Pro
Studios, we are I'm around beautiful
brothers, alhamdulillah, and our sisters
team, subhanallah, you know, working
with the sisters team, you can see that,
you know, the brotherhood is so
important because you don't feel like,
"Oh, this person is there for me because
of ABC." They're genuine. And that
really nourishes the soul to know that
you've got genuine brothers and sisters.
So, and that's really important on this
topic because we're going to watch the
video of Central C talking about him
taking the shahada. Then we're going to
go to him taking a picture with someone
called Doja Cat. She's she's she's she's
a female rap rapper in the music
industry called Doja Cat. And what
happened is the internet went crazy. The
Muslims went absolutely crazy. We
couldn't see the comment section because
I think he deleted the comment. So,
let's first go to the video of his
claiming that him being a Muslim.
Okay, so you can see he's changed his
name to Akil. And also he's British. I
thought he was an American. He's a
British rapper. So, I think he's changed
his name to Akil. Alhamdulillah, which
is not a must, but yeah. So, this is
one video of him. And there was another
brother reacting to it. Let's just
quickly watch that and then go to
the actual post where he took a picture
and he wrote in the picture, "I seek
refuge in Allah." Something along those
lines. Let's just quickly see this
reaction as well. Central C is facing
backlash after he stated he wants to
seek refuge in Allah from the devil of
the evil. And he posted this while
standing next to Doja Cat.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, so here is a post that he made and
we want to know why the internet went so
wild, and specifically Muslims. And this
is becoming really, really toxic. You
guys Well, sorry. I don't mean you guys,
but Muslims out there, subhanallah, who
are driving people away from Islam. So,
let's watch the video, inshallah. Let's
see what the post said. So, the post he
made was
Central C, I seek refuge in Allah from
the devil of the evil. Okay, so he's
taking picture with somebody who's known
to be moving a bit satanic, etc. So,
let's watch it for ourselves, inshallah.
So, half of social media believes that
he genuinely was being serious because
he was standing next to Doja Cat and his
reactions while he was next to her with
what she was wearing was just wild. So,
he posted, "I seek refuge in Allah from
the devil of evil." This man has 14,000
comments from the Muslim community
getting on him for disrespecting their
religion, bro. Well, the Muslim
community did not take too kindly to
that stating that if he's going to put
that in his caption, he shouldn't put
that while standing next to what Doja
Cat had on.
And what Doja Cat stands for. So, people
feel like he's making fun of the
religion right now. So, the backlash is
crazy. So, I mean, this is where things
gets a bit toxic with the Muslim
community, sadly. Let's be honest,
inshallah. People need to be called out.
Yes, there are genuine people who are
causing fitna and mischief and mischief
mischief on the land, subhanallah, they
should be called out. Alhamdulillah, I'm
someone I'll be I'll be honest, I'm in
the forefront of doing that to those who
need to do it. And it should be done
with good manners and akhlaq and adab.
Okay, those who are, you know, causing
hate towards the opposite gender, vice
versa, calling for evil, whatever that
might be. However, you've got somebody
who's just accepted Islam, Central C.
How are you expecting that person to
change overnight? I'm so sorry, when I
came to Islam, I had a lot of bad
traits. Bro, so much. Bro, I'm working
on sins from Jahiliyyah till this day.
Till this day, 13 years Muslim, in the
Dawah, I'm working on sins and bad
habits. It doesn't happen overnight.
Sheikh Albani, he used to drive an
automatic car. Yes, or a manual car in
Syria, if I'm not mistaken. When he went
to Saudi, they gave him a automatic car.
And he was keep looking for the clutch
cuz he was used to driving manual. And
every time he would look for the clutch,
he would press the brake and he would
have a sudden stop. And he said, "Subhan
Allah, look how long it's taking me to
adapt." And sometimes when we give
nasiha to someone, we expect immediate
changes. He took a reminder out of the
automatic car going from manual to
automatic and saying, "Subhan Allah,
look how long it's taking me to adapt to
this." And the And And even Sheikh
Albani, may Allah have mercy on him,
said, "The truth is already hard for
people to accept. Don't make it hard
with your ill manners." In the Quran, in
Surah Hujurat, verse 9 or 11, Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala says,
"Avoid negative assumptions for some
negative assumptions is a sin."
The fact that you're going out there and
saying he's mocking the deen, what
evidence do you have? He's accepted
Islam.
Doesn't need to say he's made a He's
changed his name. Alhamdulillah, okay?
Okay, doesn't It didn't have to. He's a
new Muslim. He's in an industry. You
can't just expect him tomorrow to come
and be like, "Yeah, I'm I'm going to the
masjid." Look, wallahi, I find it ajeeb.
Allah says in the Quran to the Prophet
Sallallahu Alayhi Wasallam, "We found
you lost and we guided you."
Why do you expect immediate changes,
bro? How long did it take you? And you
still And the the funny thing is those
people who come in and give hate to
Central C are the same people who are
God knows doing what evil sins in their
home. And you're there chatting, "Oh,
you're mocking the religion." My friend,
do you really take your religion
seriously? If so, then why don't you
stop all those sins that you're doing?
Or how long did it take you, sister, to
wear the hijab and the niqab? Or
brother, how long did it take you to
stop those sins that you were doing and
transaction in riba and haram? God knows
how long. So, why is it that you have
this expectation when it comes to
others? And we know that the one of the
companions who went to war, and the man
said, "Listen, I accept Islam." He said,
"Nope."
He said executed him. And they came to
the prophet and he told him the prophet
got upset. He said, "Did you He said,
"Why did you do that?" He said, "He was
only doing that out of fear." He said,
"Did you open his heart and see that he
was doing that only out of fear and not
from true submission?" Yeah? And Allah
there's a verse in the Quran Allah talks
about believers not giving salaam to
others. Why? Because of assumptions.
How do you know? How do you know that he
is in that industry he's still going to
be involved in that industry and he
genuinely meant that and said, "I seek
refuge in the devil of the evil." He's
next to someone who's satanic. Actually
makes satanic music. Okay. So, if he's
there, he's like, "Listen, bro. I'm
here. She's there." A picture was taken
whatever. It's not that easy to say,
"Oh, sorry. I can't take pictures with
you now." It doesn't work like that.
He's still in that industry. How do you
expect him What do you want him to do?
Push him away from Islam and say, "You
know what? I don't fit in." We had
someone who called on the Dawah Bros
podcast live and said, "Listen, I don't
belong here, bro." We said, "Why?" And
alhamdulillah he came back to Islam
after we had to convince him and make
dua. He said, "Bro, I've got tattoos. I
got people judge me." "Oh, look you got
tattoos." He goes, "I didn't fit in."
Why are you guys making people feel
alien, bro?
I don't care if he's wearing an earring,
he's got tattoos on his eyelids, bro. I
don't care. If he says the shahada, he
is a Muslim and you need to give him
space and let him have his journey
because believe me, if you play a role
in him leaving Islam, you are going to
take that blame. Yes, get off your
arrogant high horse righteous behavior.
Okay? Cuz Allah will punish you. Believe
me. I know of people who have left Islam
or fall fallen off the deen because of
the same arrogant attitude looking down
at people who's the innovator, who's a
kafir. Guess what happens? Allah tests
them. Why? Because of arrogance. It's
not that they genuinely care. It's
because they are nitpickers. Like Ibn
Taymiyyah says, "Some people are like
flies. They only land on poo
and feces. Yes? They don't go anywhere
else. Anything good? No, no, no. We're
going for the poo. We're going for the
feces, we're going for the wounds, where
all the bad things are. Don't be a fly
that lands on poo. Give people time to
get closer to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
in their own time. So, Central C, if
you're watching this,
here at our charity, we teach people how
to pray salah. Most likely you might
come across this. We have a free guided
prayer mat that will help teach you
learn how to pray salah. You can book a
salah instructor, and it's all of our
services for free. Why? Because we are a
charity. It's Salah Pro, you can
download our app. Use that app is free,
no subscription, no ads. It's got salah
times, Qibla finder, adhkar, tasbih,
videos on how to pray salah, ordering a
guided prayer mat. It's for absolutely
free. So, this is a message to Central
C. Tag him, send this video to him,
inshallah. He can order a guided prayer
mat for free, or we can give one to him.
I don't want to shout out. I don't want
to be in a video. I will send someone
else to give it. It's not about that. We
just want him to connect to his Lord and
learn how to pray salah. And for those
Muslims who are giving him hate, shame
on you. Okay? Stop jumping to
speculations and accusations and
assumptions. For verily it can be a sin.
That's all I wanted to say, inshallah,
brothers and sisters. says, may Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala keep Central C firm
in his deen and make him somebody who
represents the deen and bring other
people to Islam. Till next time,
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.